Let's go to the phones for the first time
in 2020 at six one, seven, eight three zero
47 50.
See what's on people's minds.
Let's go first to our caller from the 61 five
area code color from six one five.
Uh, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
What's on your mind today?
Hi David.
My name is Austin.
I'm a big payday show.
I was just wondering with this whole, um,
no, it wasn't us doing what he did last night.
What's the worst case scenario?
Like are we expecting anything to come from
this stock's going to go up, I don't know.
Austin, your, your connection is, uh, the
worst of 2020 so far.
I mean, of course this is only the first phone
call we've taken, but listen, I, I gathered
that you're asking about what's the worst
case scenario based on Trump's unauthorized
and possibly illegal assassination of the
Uranian leader.
Is that right?
Yeah, that's, that's right.
I'm sorry about the connection.
That's okay.
Listen, the worst case scenario is we get
into the most disastrous war of my lifetime,
which as I said earlier in the show that says
a lot, given that we've had Iraq and we've
had Afghanistan, and it may all be because
Donald Trump thinks it may help him get elected
in 2020.
And you know, I don't know if you've seen
some of the, that Donald Trump sent years
ago about Barack Obama and Iran saying Obama
is going to bomb Iran to try to get reelected.
And you know, it, it's unbelievable that this
is where we are.
But the worst case scenario is really bad.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
All for political gain.
It's pretty disgusting if you think about
it.
Oh, it's, it's incredible.
And you know, the, the saddest part about
it is it often works, you know, I mean, when
you look at George w Bush's reelection in
2004 it came down to, I think it was about
140,000 votes in Ohio, if I recall correctly.
And a lot of his campaign was based on, you
don't want to change horses midstream.
We're in the middle of this Iraq thing, and
when you're talking about, you know, Trump
likely losing the popular vote again in 2020
but being able to eke out a win electorally,
something like a contingent of people who,
who think we're in the middle of this thing,
let's let him finish it out.
It could actually win the election for him.
That's the sickest part of it.
Yeah.
Well, thanks for answering my question.
All right.
I appreciate it.
Hope to hear from you again.
Looks like your connection got much better
there towards the end of the call, which we
love.